hi I'm Matt Welch editor-in-chief of
Reason magazine and I'm joined today by
William Redpath the chairman of the
Libertarian Party of the United States
of America thanks for joining us since I
have you I got to ask looking back at
2008 how'd that go you hear a lot of
people sort of capital L libertarians
and small l libertarians who expressed
some disappointment that the year of Ron
Paul kind of dissipated into into
quarreling and that's a bob barr who is
sort of a high-profile candidate didn't
do as well as possible what's your take
on should you feel disappointed or happy
about it and and you know how could the
party have done better I think it's
mixed but there's a lot of positive that
happened I mean certainly everybody
wanted Bob Barr to get more votes than
he got I think it's fair to note that he
got three times approximately the number
of votes the Constitution Party
candidate and the green party candidate
he got fewer popular votes by about
200,000 and Ralph Nader but you have to
keep that in perspective I mean Ralph
Nader's name ID is far greater than Bob
bars I mean after all the Atlantic
Monthly Magazine ran an article two or
three years ago naming what they thought
were the 100 most influential people not
living but of all time in the United
States Ralph Nader was on that list at
number 99 and that took me by surprise
actually but but he has that influence
he's had influence no question and after
florida in two thousand and all that
certainly his name ID and our politics
are so name ID driven it really
shouldn't be that much of a surprise
that he pulled more votes than bob barr
but but i think in in many respects i
mean there are people in that campaign
and particularly bob barr himself who
made real sacrifices i think they did
the best the best that they could I
don't think that certainly libertarians
didn't agree with every judgment in the
campaign but you're going to run into
that with every campaign overall I think
they put in a very stalwart effort a
very solid effort to and we all wish
they'd have done better
but and I'm sure Bob Barr would be the
first person to say that but overall I
think it was it was a good campaign and
accomplished a lot with respect to other
offices first of all we came out of 2008
with ballot access and 27 states that is
a record the previous record had been 26
we described quickly we mean by ballot
access well I'm talking about
presidential or essentially statewide
ballot access where we don't have to
petition again to get back on the ballot
important of those states was North
Carolina where they had reduced the very
difficult state for ballot access we had
to get over a hundred thousand total
signatures in order to qualify for the
party for the ballot in 2008 in North
Carolina we had a tremendous candidate
for governor a Michael Munger who's
chairman of the political science
department at Duke University and they
had recently changed the law in North
Carolina not to make it easier to get on
the ballot to make it easier to stay on
the ballot once you were on lowering it
from ten percent of the vote for
president or governor to two percent he
got nearly three percent of the vote
qualifying us for ballot access in North
Carolina as a party for the next four
years and also keeping things in
perspective I mean yes I wish the
Libertarian Party were a greater
electoral success than what it is but
you know given our voting system which
sort of tilts everything toward two
dominant parties both running for the
center trying to offend as few people as
possible so they can win the single
member legislative district elections
but it's very difficult for a third
party in the United States but when you
compare the Libertarian Party in terms
of number of candidates in terms of
number of votes for US Senate for us
house for state Senate for state house
we absolutely cleaned up relative to the
other minor parties in the United States
so to that extent in comparison to our
peer parties and not the two major
parties we had a very successful 2008
you were on the ballot in all 50 states
and I think 1992 1996 and something more
like 45 this time around is it getting
more difficult to get on the ballot well
I think that 50 state ballot access for
the presidential ticket I at one point
in time I thought that certainly the
mainstream press
can't ignore us if our presidential
ticket is on the ballot in all 50 states
and that's when I really got involved in
ballot access in 1990 leading up to the
92 election and and that turned out
unfortunately not to be the case we got
on the ballot in all 50 states with our
presidential ticket and they largely
ignored us anyway I think that it's it's
not as important it's not viewed as
important in the Libertarian Party I
think as it used to be but and there
were some there were some problems that
cropped up in 2008 in terms of execution
of ballot drives that I think that that
we're going to try to avoid in the
future so I actually right now I do hope
our presidential ticket will be back on
the ballot in all 50 states and the
District of Columbia in 2012 at the very
least it should be in the high 40's is
the Tea Party movement and generalized
opposition to kind of Obama's big
government and bailout type of mentality
is that rebounding to libertarian
party's benefits do you see a more
fertile ground for what you you're
trying to do to a certain extent yes I
think we are picking up some people from
those movements but i think that the tea
parties and I spoke at the Tea Party in
Reston Virginia back on april fifteenth
2009 and they are trying not to make it
a minor party movement I think there's a
conscious effort there to not do that so
but but I do think that there are a
number of people who are joining the
party who are becoming exposed to the
party because we have people who are
involved in those Tea Party rallies talk
a little bit about yourself when did you
first become a libertarian whether
capital L or small out how did that
happen it was in the early 1980s I think
I began subscribing to Reason magazine
yes that's I think that's what happened
basically I was in high school whether
it was during the Watergate area I was a
young Democrat and we were totally
harmless don't worry everyone we SAT
around at somebody's house on Sunday
night and talked and we did nothing to
promote government that was effective I
assure you and I think I I think I
became
I sort of affiliated in my mind at least
more with the Republican Party once I
got to college and began studying
economics and then went to business
school and that takes us into the early
80s and I decided that Ronald Reagan was
not serious about cutting the size of
government and it was really
disappointment with Ronald Reagan's
unserious nasai mean he keep I hope he
wasn't the last best hope in terms of
halting or reducing the size of
government maybe but I hope not but he
just was not serious about it and if he
had been I think that he might not have
been elected to a second term but we'd
all be a lot better off today and and
also frankly the prosecution of the drug
war I thought was absolutely outrageous
on his part and and also frankly Social
Security I smelled a rat when it came to
the Social Security system a long time
ago and it was a combination of those
things that led me to believe that the
Republican Party was not serious about
cutting the size of government and there
has been nothing in the intervening
quarter century to get me to change my
mind looking at the current climate
situation Washington in the country even
the world what are your biggest fears
about what might happen and what are
your sort of centers of hope well I
think that ultimately I in terms of
centers of hope I think that ultimately
we I think the world will be better 30
years from today than it is today just
as I think it's better today than it was
30 years ago I think that that basically
in many respects time is on libertarian
side on the on the other hand I'm just I
am very much concerned about certain
policies in the United States
particularly after the election of
barack obama on the negative side I
think demographics are working against
us given that older people and we are an
aging society older people i think are
more interested in security than they
are freedom and i think that in one
sense that is working against
libertarians and the libertarian
movement in the Libertarian Party right
now but on the other hand I do think
that there is a natural progression
that the economy even though we have
problems right now will over the long
run get better there will be more
affluence and and maybe the silver
lining in the crisis is that that some
people have said isn't it don't you get
kind of depressed sometimes and I say
well don't worry we'll have a
libertarian Society someday when it's
imposed on us by the Chinese government
and and by that I mean that I do think
that ultimately that if our politicians
don't have the Kahuna's to step up and
make the tough decisions they mean to
make our foreign creditors are going to
make them for us and I hope it doesn't
come to that but I do think that there
is a natural limit to the growth of
government ultimately and and if
Americans don't decide to impose that on
this nation then like I said I think our
foreign creditors will but we have a
natural limit to our interview time here
thank you very much and for reason TV
I'm Matt Welch
you